the psychological pathologies of our age
are characterized by an over
identification with the ego
now the ego might be described as the
autobiographical mind the sort of
conductor of the orchestra right sitting
at the top of the command-and-control
hierarchical system that is the human
mind right it's the voice in your head
that lets you know that you exist and
the epidemic levels of anxiety and
depression that we're seeing in society
today are both attributed to the
excessive rumination and
self-consciousness of an overactive ego
essentially an ego that has become a
tyrant now this is not to say that our
ego doesn't serve a useful function in
the world right it's allowing me to
record this video and exercise agency
over my life to fetch water to chop wood
and to plan that's fine but that doesn't
mean that the ego cannot metastasize so
to speak that it cannot be corrupted
right an excessive amount of ego leads
to this rumination in self-consciousness
which is a kind of autoimmune disorder
where you become your own worst enemy
and it's the reason that these bumper
stickers will tell us things like the
only thing standing in your way is you
or athletes musicians and artists when
they get in the flow in the zone in the
pocket describe the experience as one in
which their mental chatter dissipates we
know from neuroscience from fMRI scans
that when people are in their flow in
their zone in a state of Rhapsody
wonderment and awe their dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex gets knocked off line
right the seat of the soul you might
call the egos throne is called the
default mode network right and the
default mode Network gets shut off line
gets knocked off line during these
intense and jolting encounters right
such as traveling somewhere new hurling
yourself into the abyss and realizing
that it
a featherbed taking a psychedelic drug
in a controlled ritual environment right
diving into a new relationships it seems
that these these intense and
destabilizing experiences can often be
ecstatic because they occasion a
subjective sense of relief from self
right a transcendence of the ego and
when we write as Jerry Garcia says to
get really high is to forget yourself
and to forget yourself is to see
everything else often people who suffer
from treatment-resistant depression see
everything gray or so over identified
with their own entropy with their own
gravity with their own weight that the
walls are caving in it's a failure of
the imagination according to Kierkegaard
from which depressed people cannot see
the light outside the dark tunnel
they're stuck in that black hole of hell
all right this is a disease of the self
same to with paranoid anxiety or PTSD
these are people that whose past trauma
is now contaminating the astounding
frontier of the present with terror of
impending doom this metastasized overly
active ego has led to a generation of
sufferers suffering that is unfathomable
to grasp 800 thousand people a year now
are committing suicide a larger number
than the amount of people that die from
natural disasters and armed conflict
combined in fact a friend of mine from
high school I just found out killed
himself by hurling himself off a balcony
what has gone so wrong with us that our
minds have become poisoned and
disconnected from the world and from
each other what is missing I think is an
egoless communion with everything what
is missing I think is the nourishing
experience of connecting with something
larger than yourself
and if psychedelic deployed responsibly
in guided environments can be the
therapeutic intervention that hurls us
into a place beyond self where we lose
track of our own boundaries and
experience an egoless communion with the
radians and Rhapsody of nature and the
cosmos that occasions a mystical
experience that catalyzes an aesthetic
orgasm we can finally all experience
with psychedelic philosopher terence
mckenna's at the moment in which you
become what you behold if it's a
beautiful song or a radiant landscape
you become the music you become the
landscape William James the American
psychologist used to say your experience
is what you attend to and the problem
with the pathologies of our age with the
anxiety with the depression is that
people no longer feel agency over what
they attend to they're stuck in these
loops they're stuck in these compulsive
overthinking they no longer feel free
they no longer have agency there's
nothing new to explore but they're wrong
they're wrong Michael Pollan describes
the virginal noticing of the sense8
world that occurs when you lose track of
your own boundaries right when all
signals forwards and backwards get
knocked off line the astounding frontier
of the present reveals itself and all of
a sudden that sense of first sight
unencumbered by knowingness awakens us
to our common ecstasy for a transitory
enchanted moment we hold our breath were
compelled into aesthetic contemplations
we barely understand we're face to face
with something can measure it to our
capacity for wonder this cosmological
wonderment this this moment of ecstasy
this astronaut overview effect in which
we connect the dots and see the big
picture is what Carl Sagan's describes
as understanding as a kind of ecstasy
this religious experience can absolve us
of our suffering we can die into the
moment and we can be reborn Alan Moore
in his book the archetype of initiation
says if you cannot submit you cannot die
and if you cannot die you cannot be
reborn it saddens me that so many people
are suffering from mental distress
anxiety depression despair all men lead
lives of quiet desperation they tell us
but I think there's hope I think there's
hope I think the future is psychedelic I
think the future is transformation and
healing and so thank you to all the
brave souls support all the brave souls
carving this new path Rick Doblin
Michael Pollan the multidisciplinary
Association of psychedelic studies Johns
Hopkins University Imperial College of
London you guys are doing brave work
keep it up
you